ああああああ
今日はあと一つあのねアンナリサ動画でをこれたくないんですけどが嫌なことがあって
僕それを貯めておくことが
できないこともないんですけど twitter とかで言っちゃってるんでその理由
をちゃんと言うしかないんでちょっと言わせていただきますあのめっちゃ怒ってます
twitter でつぶやいたんですよ
はっきりと連れております iphone 通った
変わってないんですよあーこれなんで変わってないかはわかりますそれに観測が起こっ
ているんですよ
もうツイッターで堂々と宣言して iphone を通っとって宣言してそれでなお
まだ支えられてない
この夏の怒りについてちょっと皆さんに飾らせていただきたいと思います良ければ依存
を変えようって言ってるのに変えてないんでもうちょっと
boo さんと言わなきゃいけないと思ってるのよせていただきます
な図案の僕これ iphone 7+なんですよ田舎ユーチューバーってその動画で
アプリとゲームとかでよく使うんで出来ればいいスペックんだと常に使ってタイアのお
仕事をさせていただく3としてというですね仕事上できるだけ最新型のイースのを使い
たいんですよアプリのお仕事とかもあるんでいいスマホでやりたいなと思ってちょっと
8点はみよっ
撮らせて頂いて次は絶対変えようと思って iphone 天理 s max
結構早めに予約したんですよ6つ早く予約しに行ったときその予約の人が iot
スマックですね
あまだ全然大丈夫ですあのお客様に番目でございますおめでとうございますみたいな
感じで
絶対をこれゲットできんじゃんと思ってちょっといそうでしょ2番目にを訳したんです
よこれ
エスター多分大丈夫なのであの当日お越しいただけるとみたいな感じで言われて楽しみ
にしながら待ってるんですけどさぁ
はいおれ
2番ねだぞ2番に予約して手に入れないって在庫となったんじゃ
ってを頃としたんですけどこれに関してはもう別にねお店に起こることでもないと思う
んですよ
入ってくるその iphone の風がわかんないって言ってたんでだから結局多分
当時天一第二回前提 s max が届かなかったみたいでございます色も随分なくて
誰だよ
2番目に予約したらさぁフェアリともうじゃんっ
lost
ペイントも点はおらずいずれもせながら攻めてきたら願いもテイク罰にしたがろやー
ブービーよっちあああーーデイパックじゃああーんあーんにょんにょ役佐藤卓さん
みんなで携帯ショップの中で誰が iphone を呈す max を一つだけ買うと
思ってるんだよ
さっきゅん後面接と twitter 4
たんですけどまだ iphone 7のままですねまず普通に悔しかった
今日別に聞いても次の入荷がいつかわかんないからごめんなさいみたいな感じで特に今
のところ僕が iphone テニスマックにいつ帰れるかという見込みは
ないです何で俺も外さ俺もあぁん
ありゃ言ったら
あのドラとかね音飼った犬とか
にっしゃんがやってるんあの顔5時や動きゃ取ればやりだガーター
ああああああ
スープーあの猫と母親であって覚えていっ
怒っても仕方ないんですよ奢っても助けないんだけどせめて特に誰が悪いわけでもあり
ません
まあしいて言うなら少なかった在庫が悪いぐらいでしょでもね僕ら
道具はあきらめませんよ
絶対黒で設定を持ってね絶対この手で iphone テーズ max を手に入れ
てるじゃーん
[音楽]